cities states and countries around the
world are all taking a look at a bitcoin
obviously we've seen cities in the
united states put forward legislation to
make bitcoin legal tender we've also
seen countries like el salvador go ahead
and plug their entire country into the
bitcoin network now we have another
country mexico in central america that's
looking to make bitcoin legal tender
within their jurisdiction a mexican
senator is going to put forward
legislation to make bitcoin legal tender
what exactly am i talking about well
here's a quote from indira kempus
mexican senator who said we need bitcoin
to be legal tender in mexico because if
it is not so if we do not make that
decision as el salvador did it is very
difficult to take action she then went
on to say it is clear to me that
financial exclusion is one of the public
problems that few of us have addressed
with feasible alternatives and that this
type of technology is allowing us to
generate an alternative so that millions
of people can be included in the
financial system now what's really
interesting is as we've seen el salvador
make bitcoin legal tender they've kicked
off a domino effect throughout south and
central america we've seen country after
country after country have local state
or national politicians come forward and
say i think we should follow suit what
president buchelli did in el salvador
has become a milestone moment and to see
a country like mexico following suit to
see politicians openly talking about
adopting a decentralized digital
currency as legal tender my guess is
that over the next 10 to 20 years every
single country is going to adopt bitcoin
as legal tender those that are early
those that act with courage and
conviction early on they're the ones who
are going to be rewarded most and so
ultimately seeing mexico start to do
this we shouldn't be surprised but you
gotta tip your hat and say i hope that
they get this push forward hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time